and the spirit award the best feature  goes to  nomad land  [Music]  [Applause]  thank you thank you so much to film a  dependent to  to searchlight um congratulations to  our fellow nominees you make  extraordinary movies you push the  boundaries of culture and we are so  honored to be nominated with you  in our film um bob wells says to fern  that um you've come to the right place  to connect with your tribe and with your  community  and you film independent you are a  community and we are so honored to be  recognized by our tribe  the last time that uh francis uh was  here  she uh she had just met chloe and that  began the  incredible journey we've all been on uh  for the last couple years and we  couldn't have done it without all the  hearts and hands our fellow  collaborators our fellow filmmakers  who were the nomad land companies so to  all of you  we accept this on your behalf as well  thank you thank you thank you  you